hi my name is Colin Graham and I'm the
animation director of watch dogs too
today we want to give you a look at our
free roaming demo and give you a more
detailed look at the open world and the
Bay Area this video is recorded from an
alpha build of watchdogs to running on
ps4 and watch dogs too we've expanded
our hacking tools to give the players
more options by tapping and releasing
the l1 shoulder button we can do a
contextual quick hack on this person if
we want more hacking options we simply
filled the l1 button while focusing on
our target now we can see that there's
for contextual hacks available on this
car using the l1 button in two different
ways allows the players to have fast
access to the most common hacks but it
also opens up additional contextual
hacks this gives the player more hacking
options than before we've also added a
net hack view to the hacking tool kit
which allows you to toggle a digital
filter to see the world like a hacker we
can easily pick out hacking
opportunities and also pick out strange
digital signals and data anomalies that
are of interest to us the orange signal
indicates that there's a person whose
digital profile has interesting
properties for us to investigate so
let's take a closer look when we're
exploring the world nethack is a very
useful tool to help us identify people
or items of interest it's a really good
idea when you explore the open world to
use your net hack and look around
because you never know what you'll find
we can hack into his phone and read his
text messages to get a clue about what's
happening as a hacker it's really easy
for Marcus to get someone's personal
information this guy's text messages
indicate that he's experiencing strange
behavior happening on his phone he seems
to think that it happens every time he
comes to this exact area let's see what
her dead SEC teammates think about these
strange signals
found something weird sweet dish no I
mean my MC catcher detector is going off
we really need to find a better name for
that why that's the technical name my
stingray sniffer tells me somebody's
leaching data off of people's phones
below looks like the date is going to
point out see weird weird and Marcus has
detected that there's an illegal
stingray box deployed somewhere around
Coit Tower we now have access to a new
dead psyche operation and we can track
it with a dead psych appt you can do any
operation you want in the order that you
want as long as you've discovered it and
it's in your dead set cap with the net
hack we can see the Stingray box is
deployed all the way on the top of coit
tower but says the tower is closed we're
going to have to find another way to
reach it you still have a little out of
your nose and watchdogs to Marcus has
some custom built toys to play with so
we can just deploy our quadcopter and
fly it to the top Coit Tower is an
iconic landmark known for its great view
from here you can see the whole city is
accessible you can visit landmarks like
sutro tower you can explore golden gate
park or take a drive across the bridge
to Marin you can sail the bay on a
sailboat or you can visit Alcatraz maybe
take a selfie with the sea lions on pier
39 you can also travel across the bay
bridge to Oakland or take the freeway
south the Silicon Valley you can also
take your time and explore san
Francisco's diverse neighborhoods like
Chinatown Castro or even the tenderloin
[Music]
with the drone we can easily hack into
the Stingray box and track its source
this one is operated by grace drum we're
illegally installing these boxes all
across the city the open world is full
of opportunities like this dead SEC
operation all you have to do is explore
the environment using nethack in the
profiler to find them all there we go
this one has a break from trail I can
follow nice looks like grapes drum set
up a warehouse out by the piers I'm on a
bet I can find some shady [ __ ] in there
definitely association we can open our
smartphone and select the dead psyche
app to track this operation we use the
dead SEC app to manage all of our
activities and watchdogs we can see the
objectives on our map and it's not very
far so we can drive there pretty quickly
the noodle map app can be used to locate
different landmarks in areas of interest
the entire Bay Area is yours to explore
from the very beginning of the game so
you don't need to unlock anything
there's also a shop on pier 39 where we
can customize Marcus's outfit and
there's some other open-world activities
we can check it along the way too let's
take this car and head down to the
waterfront cars are particularly
vulnerable to a hacker like Marcus and
you can acquire a skill that allows you
to simply unlock any car in the game
with your phone one of the biggest
feedbacks we got from the fans after the
first watchdogs game was about the
driving we've significantly improve the
driving to make it more responsive and
accessible to a wider number of players
driving was reworked extensively with a
team of experts from Ubisoft reflections
this is a particularly important
improvement because San Francisco is
known for its steep hills and his type
pointing streets
of course driving and hack and go hand
in hand and you can still hack steam
pipes traffic lights and you can also
hack individual vehicles as you can see
it's much easier to drive through the
city and wash dogs too let's pull up
here at iconic pier 39 and take a quick
look around up ahead is a clothing store
so let's go give Marcus a new look each
clothing store has the style of the
people who live in that area so as you
travel around the world you can start to
build a wardrobe that's as diverse as
San Francisco itself there are over 700
unique items of clothing that Marcus can
purchase to wear with over a billion
possible combinations we can go into the
fitting room menu and browse a selection
of items found in the store let's start
by switching out Marcus's jacket each
item of clothing in the shop is hand
crafted to fit Marcus's overall look you
can mix and match any pieces of clothing
you want you can change your hat classes
face mask bag shirt pants and shoes
there's some nice normcore hoodies in
here but I think we should go with the
shirt with the giant skull on it let's
take a look at what we got for shoes
since people who come to pier 39 are
often tourists we have styles of shoes
that they would buy we can go with these
comfortable Gator shoes or maybe some
open toe sandals or if you really want
to make a statement you can buy the
awkward socks and sandals combo in the
end though I think we should go with
stars and stripes chucks we could really
stay here all day trying on clothes and
each store has a wide variety of
clothing options so you can really make
Marcus look the way you want a biker
leather to hip hop from pinstripe suits
to tie dye tank tops you can really
craft the look that's unique to you
then watch talks to you manage your
activities from your smartphone there's
an app shop a media player a dense a cap
and a research app that allows you to
develop new skills let's take a look in
the app shop to find the Scout X app San
Francisco is full of iconic landmarks so
as you explore the world you'll find you
Scout X objectives in the app once we've
installed it we can find nearby
landmarks and go check them out when you
visit San Francisco there's so many
great landmarks to visit the Scared X
app will be like your tour guide and
watch dogs too we're right near the crap
statue on Pier 39 so let's go to that
one right now
these tourists have the right idea we'll
just pop open our phone and select our
camera and take a picture of this giant
crab let's make it a selfie and use the
California vibe filter what's that
uploading the photos to the Scout X app
would give you more followers and you'll
need those followers to progress through
the game so we had a look around we
bought some new clothes let's get back
on track and head to that next pier
we'll take care of that stolen data at
the grace trim site
we can see the objective marker in our
mini map and it's also displayed in
orange at the end of the pier it's park
our car past the scissor lift and go
Scout the place on for it operations and
watchdogs to are almost always a free
approach so you can go after the
objective from any direction let's start
by getting it to cover and scanning our
enemies and see if we can spot the
objective from there we can make a plan
of attack we can launch our drone and
scout the area we can use our nethack
view to see that there are guards
patrolling the rooftop and the objective
is in a small office there are also some
civilian workers that might notice us so
we need to avoid them too in the net
hack view we can see that the door is
electronically locked but it can be
bypassed by a junction box on the lower
level the connection is shown in a red
line unfortunately that box is protected
by an armed guard and an attack dog so
we'll probably have trouble if we try to
sneak past the dog in person but luckily
Marcus has another toy which is the RC
jumper this little guy is small and much
harder for enemies to detect the RC
jumper is another dead set gadget that
gives Marcus a different way to approach
obstacles in the layout the RC jumper
has this cool little robotic arm that's
been hacked into the body this allows
him to physically interact with objects
and allows Marcus to stay safely hidden
now the junction box is unlocked and we
can open the door upstairs we can hack
that scissor lift that we passed on the
way in and reach the rooftop by hacking
into the OS of this is Olaf to Marcus
can take remote control of it not only
can you raise it up and down but you can
actually drive it around anywhere you
want in the world this level of control
gives players total freedom when
dreaming up an approach to a mission a
first challenge is to get past the guard
in front of us so let's hack into the
security camera and see how he might be
vulnerable there's an industrial air
conditioner unit that we can hack you
can set it to explode when the guard
comes close and we can hack it to
attract the guard with a strange noise
the guard will go investigate the noise
and walk straight into the trap we set
and just like that we've taken out the
guard create a distraction and slipped
into the compound
a more direct way to neutralize a guard
is to use the non-lethal stun gun Marcus
has an array of non-lethal tools and
techniques and you can complete the
entire game without actually killing a
single enemy since we already unlock
this door with our RC jumper we can just
quick hack it to open it now we're in
the room we just need to install one of
our custom dead SEC boxes into this
bloom terminal and we've completed our
final objective all that's left to do
now is escape undetected each operation
we undertake would give us more
followers more followers will allow you
to take on even bigger operations so
let's get off this pier and explore a
little bit more tell me you [ __ ] that
right where I left an expensive little
present in their system and they're
going to pay for it down you sound like
Jimmy sister hell yeah
[Music]
up ahead will notice there's another
player hanging event he's easy to spot
because of the purple icon and the
gamertag over his head in watch dogs
your game session can be seamlessly
merged and you will often encounter
other players exploring the world just
like you this guy looks really friendly
we have an opportunity to join up and
form a co-op party so let's send him an
invite
now that we're joined in a session we
can complete co-op missions together and
take on even bigger and tougher targets
to hackers are better than one
we're going to head across the bay to
Prescott which is in north oakland to
infiltrate a gang layer we can get there
by driving across the bay bridge
together
alright we can see that we're in a much
different neighborhood than before this
is Prescott a sub district of north
oakland and the location of our next
cooperation with our partner we can go
together and activate this mission
Marcus we have operations popping up
everywhere some of them are to hacker
jobs where you need me sending you the
coordinates and Marcus it works both
ways when you need help fire off a call
and we'll send someone your way to the
assist
this area is a free approach so we can
tackle it any style we want since we're
now to hackers working together we'll
cover our partner from the sky and help
them out with some well-timed tax we can
distract this guard by hacking his phone
and our friend will take him down very
stealthily will continue to scout the
area and find more lookouts like this
gang member on the rooftop can
automatically tag them and what's their
tagged both players can see them our
partner is going to sneak up on the
rooftop and take out this card and we
can help him with some well-timed hacks
if we use a contextual hack on this
transformer box we can attract the guard
a partner has an easy shot with a stun
gun from that distance using the net
hack view again we could see that
there's a lock box connected by red
connection lines to a row on the other
side of the compound inside this
probably see our two targets meeting up
and it's a perfect place to take them
down simultaneously we need to get that
box unlocked and get into that room as
we continue to scout this area we can
see this compound has a lot more guards
than the last one and they look very
heavily armed we'll need to take care of
these guards if we get detected there's
also a car parked in the garage so we
might need that to escape later let's go
back to our friend and get them to
disable that junction box so we can
unlock the door to our target the drone
has a lot of flexibility and it's small
and hard to detect but the trade-off is
that you can't physically interact with
objects like this junction box but it's
not a problem for our man on the ground
to do that for us the signal lines have
change from red to blue so now we know
that we can open the doors and get to
our targets
scouting face is done so let's get up on
that rooftop with our partner and get
close enough to neutralize these enemies
we can hack these junction boxes and set
a proximity trigger on them they'll
explode if an enemy passes through them
but they won't be triggered if we pass
through them ourselves you can also
deploy electroshock lines from our
inventory and they're fully hackable too
it's a good idea to leave traps for your
enemies in case they try to flank you
our partners camped out by the door
ready to rush into the room but we're
going to create a distraction first
we'll get into position behind these
crates and this time we'll launch our RC
jumper once our partner opens the door
will zip in and create a distraction
our jumper has another feature to it can
launch foul-mouthed ons and make people
angry now's our chance the gang leaders
are distracted so let's rush the room
this guy was pretty tough but getting a
thunder ball to the face will ruin his
day now we have a cell phone and all the
evidence that we need we just need to
plan a way out of here we can switch
back to our quadcopter which is hovering
where we left it and take a look at
what's going on from the sky we can see
one of the guards is rushing up the
stairs to help his boss but our partner
has that door covered with his dead SEC
rifle there's another guard on the
ground level who's alerted to our
gunfire so let's use a contextual hack
on him we've changed this profile to
make a rival gang think that he's a
police informant the rival game will
come to this compound and take care of
him for us things are heating up so
we're going to have to improvise a
little bit we can hack the car in the
garage and reverse it away from the
enemies so we can use it for our getaway
the rival gang just arrived and they've
engaged in a gang war with the remaining
guards these guys aren't messing about
their armed with grenades and body armor
will take some higher ground and use our
dead sack 3d printed assault rifle to
take them on
there's still one guard left so we can
hack his headset which leaves him
vulnerable to it take that let's take
our stolen ride and get out of here
before cops show up
and just like that we're home free who
took down both gang leaders we got the
evidence we needed and we triggered a
gang war and we escaped without getting
killed that's teamwork to hackers and
one successful dead SEC operation let's
take a minute to talk about a brand new
multiplayer pvp event called online
bounty and the player commits a crime
the police will respond and pursue the
player until he can escape from the
police we call that the felony system
well you're in the felony a bounty event
can occur a bounty event allows up to
three other online players to join the
pursuit and try to kill the player for
as long as the felony lasts as the
target player of the bounty your
objective is to evade the felony and the
pursuing players rewards are given for
neutralizing the hunters and the
objective of the hunters is to
neutralize the target player bounty is a
seamless PvP event that's triggered by
your player style and how you interact
with the police if you are the type of
player who's always in conflict with
police will have a higher chance of
having a bounty placed on you but if you
can neutralize the hunters you'll get
additional rewards I hope you've enjoyed
our walkthrough of the open world of
watchdogs to and I hope to see you
online November 15th click here to join
dead sick and receive exclusive in-game
rewards and more subscribe to our
YouTube channel and be the first to see
new trailers and behind-the-scenes
action